bonjour tu es ou clair merci de répondre
à nos questions on dirait que cet après
midi sur arte france geoffroy roux de
bézieux le président du medef dit qu'il
y a eu des impacts financiers dans les
centres commerciaux à cause du passé ni
terre bruno le maire a affirmé le
contraire qui croire alors cet argument
est avancé fréquemment devant les
tribunaux administratifs par les
différents requérant ça dépend
véritablement de la situation locale et
décrit bruno s'ils voulaient ya certains
tribunaux qui ont considéré qu
effectivement le passé du père avait un
impact sur la fréquentation et sur le
chiffre d'affaires ou on a vu par
exemple le tribunal administratif de
toulouse rejeté cet argument au motif
que les requérants n'avançait pas
suffisamment de preuves quant à la perte
de ces chiffres d'affaires c'est
véritablement une question et une
appréciation qui est très toxique et qui
va dépendre véritablement du magistrat
parce que si vous voulez ses grands
centres commerciaux même si ils ont une
perte de fréquentation de 15% on peut
toujours estimer que leur situation
économique n'est pas encore dans une
situation périlleuse où wade
il ya le tribunal administratif de paris
a dit qu'on garde elle passe sanitaires
dans les centres commerciaux parisien
mais dans l'essonne dans les yvelines
c'était avant-hier aussi dans les
hauts-de-seine c'est le contraire
juridiquement on se tourne vers quoi ça
semble compliqué quand même
d'accord c'est ça semble compliqué et
c'est la situation qui est compliqué si
vous voulez chaque préfet peut prendre
un arrêté et chaque préfet a pris son
arrêté m'a motivé d'une manière
particulière est propre à la situation
de son département et c'est donc pour
cette raison que l'on a plusieurs
ordonnances qui annule ou qui
maintiennent le pas salutaire
concernant les rues de sel on a vu de
l'arrêté du préfet ne concernait qu'un
seul centre commercial de plus de 20
mille mètres carrés et c'est là dessus
qu'il ya eu quelques faits baisse
puisque le magistrat a dit pourquoi
l'appliquer un seul centre commercial de
20 mètres carrés alors que les autres ne
sont pas concernés et quant à la
décision du tribunal administratif de
paris elle s'interprète elle se comprend
si vous voulez dans la dans le fil du
temps de ses décisions on a eu d'abord
les premières décisions du tribunal
administratif de cergy qui sont tombés
ou blanc a suspendu le pass et si vous
voulez le ministère de la santé a fait
appel de cette décision donc le conseil
d'état a été saisi
postérieurement à cette saisine en appel
du conseil d'état le tribunal
administratif de paris avait été saisi
en attendant que le conseil de concéder
la statue et harmonise la jurisprudence
le tribunal administratif de paris a
préféré rejeter pour le défaut d'urgence
mais tout le monde saisit tout le monde
comme on l'a dit un c'est un véritable
imbroglio dans les semaines à venir à
quoi s'attendre d'autant plus qu
emmanuel macron a dit tout à l'heure qui
n'était pas contre le fait de détendre
le pass sanitaire au delà du 15 novembre
selon ses mots je cite il est trop tôt
pour le dire comment vont se positionner
le conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel et pour quelles
conséquences par par la suite pour les
français pour la vie de tous les jours
tout simplement
alors je pense que le conseil d'état par
sa décision va apporter un peu de clarté
dans les différentes jurisprudence mais
il faut se remettre un petit peu aussi
se retourner un petit peu sur le passé
et sur l'année qu'on a vécu et il faut
se souvenir que ce mouvement de recours
on avait eu quelque chose de similaire
au moment des salles de sport où on
avait eu par exemple les arrêtés
préfectoraux de l'hérault qui avait été
contestée et annulée et on avait vu
également les tribunaux administratifs
de rennes suspendent les arrêter pour
les salles de sport le tribunal
administratif de nantes le maintenir et
finalement la jurisprudence qui avaient
été posées par le conseil d'état avait
permis quand même de clarifier la
position alors après est ce que cette
norme va évoluer peut-être on connaît
l'importance du but et parole du
président de la république dans
l'évolution normative notamment dans ce
contexte du coni d'où une simple
décision peut avoir beaucoup d'impact on
l'a vu par exemple avec l'instauration
du passé ni terre et l'effet sur les
vaccinations après les déclarations des
menus et de macron est ce que le
lobbying des centres commerciaux va
porter ses fruits est ce que le medef va
être entendu on va voir peut-être que
cette norme va évoluer on va d'abord
avoir une première piste avec le conseil
d'état et peut-être que
réglementairement ça va évoluer voilà
dans les prochains jours avec la prise
de position des manuels macro manuel
m'apprend qui doit s'exprimer d'ici à
quelques instants pour marseille du côté
du palais du pharo merci était au clair
d'avoir répondu à nos questions j'ai un
peu que vous êtes avocat spécialiste des
libertés publiques